we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
here is a really great question about
how to deal with people who do a certain
really annoying thing during political
debates and conversations take a listen
hey David uh sir this is Jose I just had
a quick question yes I was wondering if
you had any advice to what you would
tell somebody if you're having a
discussion with them about politics
where they just immediately go to what
about him they don't really bring
anything to the conversation they just
say what about this what about that what
about this yep just need some help uh
just with that thank you so this is
super common the way it might go is you
say listen the evidence is
indicative that Trump committed crimes
and should be charged and then the
person you're talking to goes well what
about Hunter bite
understand that sometimes when people do
the what about this other thing
it's because their brain is scrambled
and I'm not saying this to make fun of
people but what I mean is there are lots
of people who they don't organize their
thoughts in their head
and they can't think straight and so
they're just bouncing all over the place
and it's sort of like a cognitive issue
of getting them to actually focus in on
the one thing you're trying to talk
about that's one category you then also
have people who use what about ISM as
deliberate deception or to try to
undermine or distract and create red
herrings they use it sort of like as a
tool
uh very deliberately and in bad faith
and then you've got people who it's not
that their brain is totally scrambled
and they're not completely bad faith
they're just kind of like a little
ignorant and they don't realize that
there's all these separate issues and
and we we should deal with these issues
one at a time so Step One is sort of try
to figure out if the person doing the
what about ism is doing it for one or
the other of those possibilities that I
mentioned bad faith brain scrambled sort
of confused try to figure that out and
one of the best tools that I find when
somebody brings out this other thing
that they want to talk about is to say
hey you know what that may also be a
problem I'm glad to talk about that but
let's stick with this topic first
resolve it and then we can talk about
that other thing very quickly you'll
know if you say something like that when
the what about ISM pops up whether
you're dealing with a brain scramble or
someone functioning in bad faith or
someone who's just a little bit confused
and sometimes they'll say oh you know
what you're right okay yeah let's figure
this thing out first then we can talk
about that other thing another
tool these aren't even really tools
these are literally just one liners to
try to refocus the conversation another
thing that can sometimes be said when
the what about ISM pops up is something
along the lines of can we just decide
and agree what we're talking about now I
know there's all these different things
we can talk about you're wanting to talk
about something different
let's just agree what we're now talking
about and oftentimes it'll get the other
person to have to actually tell you what
it is we're talking about and if they're
doing a what about ISM with something
that really isn't related but what about
that time when Obama drew a red line in
Syria
doesn't really have anything to do with
the Qatari World Cup does it right the
example sometimes that will also get
people refocused because you're letting
them decide what you're talking about
and sometimes it'll become evident that
the two things aren't related if you're
trying to talk about criminal charges
against Trump and they want to talk
about Obama's red line and you say can
you just tell me what are we talking
about right now just so we can finish
that it's going to be hard for them to
go well we're talking about criminal
charges against Trump and Obama's Red
Line in Syria a lot of people when they
say that out loud would go wait a second
that those two things aren't even
remotely connected that doesn't make any
sense okay so some ideas for dealing
with the what aboutists Friday December
23rd we are doing a one-day membership
special hugely discounted last one of
the Year remember we're an independent
media show and we're funded by our
viewers but we're going to do something
extra
we are going to donate your first
month's discounted payment when you sign
up Friday with a coupon code that is
forthcoming we will donate that first
month's payment to charity to be sent as
cash to people in need I'm talking about
people for whom a few bucks makes a big
difference people living on a dollar a
day people living on two dollars a day
in different parts of the world we've
never done this before and we have an up
to fifteen thousand dollar match so if
you have a six dollar a month membership
coupon code smacks it down to three
dollars a month we will donate your
three dollars and we will match it with
another three dollars we've never tried
this we're trying to do something for
the people
uh if you want to be notified about this
it'll be in an email that goes out
Friday morning
get on my newsletter at davidpackman.com
it's free to get on it you just type in
your email address at the top right of
the page and Friday you will get all of
the details on today's bonus show
the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is coming to the U.S he may
already be here he will be addressing
Congress tonight it is a big deal when a
foreign leader addresses Congress we
will talk about it Elon Musk will resign
as head of Twitter and many of you wrote
to me and said this is great news a few
of you wrote to me and said this is bad
news they're going to install a flunky
he'll do all the same terrible things
and then Elon Musk can say I'm not even
in charge anymore and shift blame we'll
talk about it and we are also going to
talk about the confusion and the
falsehoods that have been spreading
in China as China has reversed its
so-called zero coveted policy which of
course didn't really lead to zero covet
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com we
will see you then